are you nearly finished we I don't know
last year last March or April yes yes so
you must be nearly finished that's cuz I
broke my ankle we had to shut down but
once weeks away the ankle this is that
so are you fully recovered are you well
it's still broken but I'm doing well no
you're kidding is it still broken yeah I
mean it's not fully healed but we're
shooting but that's nuts because you've
seen though you've seen a bunch of years
you're running and doing stuff again
yeah now we have a release date so we
got to keep going
otherwise you'll end up going lies yes I
probably I'm sure you all saw the the
footage in in it was in the papers and
things online of the accident yes and I
think we all kind of thought well how
did you break an ankle doing that does
it look like you should have broken your
jaw or something I know everyone said
that was the stunt I mean I'm gonna run
across and hit the side of the wall and
then pull myself over that wasn't the
mistake so you're always meant to not
yes land on the roadways okay so what
you know you brought us some footage I
think this is so cool to see this from
the different angles it's what I I can't
watch this it's fine there's one clip
but I will warn you it's not for the
screen you'll see I'm wearing two wires
they're basically just safety wires
because I'm I go at a full tilt and I'm
sprinting as hard as I can and I hit the
side of the wall and that's the stunt I
hit the side of the wall and then I'm
chasing after Henry actually and all his
fault I blame him I can't decide the
wall and then I climb up on the wall and
I'm supposed to run Pascal okay so we've
got this is the shot from behind you so
this is you see the the speed and the
momentum of the run and it's in London
there we go so it's keeping me okay so
here he goes do that
but you get my point you think how did
you break a leg so let's look at her to
the side just list it from the side so
this is from the side here we go we shot
it with three camera okay here he goes
and boom now now we've got a camera
which focuses on the foot now if you are
squeamish don't watch this show it to me
and I'm like yeah
I mean that bone doesn't pop out or
anything but it is an odd angle for
anyone's foot to be spun should ever
have to do this yeah here we go oh my
gosh so he jumps that speed that
momentum here we go
and watch that whatsit here here is why
here is why Tom Cruise gets paid the big
bucks okay because this is it from the
front angle okay so you've just seen
what's happened to his foot now watch
this I knew I broke it instantly to town
now anyone else to go well that's over
No
[Applause]
do it again I knew I knew instantly was
broke and I run past camera
we got the shot it's in the movie that
profile shot both those shots are in the
movie everybody said when when you go to
run out of shot oh that's so him like
with your foot hanging off I just when I
said sorry guys it's broken you know
take me to the hospital it's broken
every that's a wrap everyone everyone
crew got on the phone and made their
vacation arrangement I made it baby
[Music]
you